cristóbal buenas noches es casualidad
que el anuncio de trump que es lo más
cercano que ha estado de una concesión
llegue justo el día de acción de gracias
cuando el país entero está enfocado en
celebrar con sus familias
no no es casualidad y todo el mundo está
precisamente en familia en las mesas
compartiendo la comida incluso pues
periodistas de hecho varios medios de
comunicación se demoraron en sacar la
noticia en ponerla en primera plana
además pues lo que dijo concretamente el
presidente de trump es que va a esperar
hasta el 14 de diciembre que es cuando
los delegados electorales se reúnen y
depositan su voto electoral para
entonces pues confirmar su derrota en
este momento pues yo bailé tiene 306
votos electorales donald trump pues
tiene 232 votos electorales sin embargo
creo que sigue insistiendo en este
fraude electoral insiste en este fraude
para demorar la certificación
precisamente de estos resultados y que
los delegados no puedan votar el 14 de
diciembre supuestamente por este fraude
electoral una acusación que no ha tenido
pues mucho éxito en los estrados
judiciales
trump está aprovechando estas últimas
semanas que le quedan en la casa blanca
para adelantar entonces proyectos y
perdones como el que hizo recientemente
con michael flynn